He-Man has become a pop culture icon, with his
magic sword defending his home planet of Eternia.
But, did you know he came from Star Wars
toys, or that he once became Shazam?
Here's the untold truth about He-Man
and the Masters of the Universe.
The 1980s saw a major explosion in action figures.
This was largely due to the "Star Wars"
film franchise and the popular figurines
of characters like Luke Skywalker and Darth
Vader made by Kenner Toys. Surprisingly,
however, Kenner wasn't the first toy company that
received an offer to produce "Star Wars" toys.
In 1976, Ray Wagner, the CEO of Mattel
Incorporated, declined George Lucas' asking
price of $750,000 to produce a toy line of "Star
Wars" action figures. Wagner undoubtedly ended up
regretting the decision when the toys became one
of the most lucrative parts of the film franchise.
Mattel then quickly launched several medieval and
science fiction-themed toy lines of their own.
They hoped to create the next
hit action figure in the bargain.
According to the book "Mastering the Universe:
He-Man and the Rise and Fall of a Billion-Dollar
Idea," Roger Sweet, a designer at Mattel,
decided on the generic name "He-Man" to build
a toy line around. Although none of the aspects
of He-Man's mythology had been developed yet,
the simplicity of the name was key. This
gave the company's team of designers a mostly
blank canvas that they could use to create
virtually any story world they imagined.
Today, it's impossible to separate the name
"He-Man" from the image of a massively muscled,
blonde barbarian. But when Mattel
began developing the He-Man concept,
the toy line could have gone in
any number of different directions.
At one point, Mattel executives were given a
choice between three prototype models of He-Man:
a barbarian, a soldier,
and a science-fiction hero.
Weirdly, the sci-fi version of He-Man
wore a helmet that looked very much like
the Mandalorian helmet worn by Boba Fett in
"The Empire Strikes Back." But the helmet
reappeared in a recent version of Vykron in
the Masters of the Universe Classics line.
Ultimately, the barbarian version of He-Man proved
the most appealing to the executives. The "He-Man
and the Masters of the Universe" backstory then
went on to become a sword-and-sorcery epic.
However, it's strange to think that, at one
point, He-Man could have been Mattel's version
of a Mandalorian. Lucasfilm likely wouldn't
care for the design though, so it's lucky
that He-Man decided to bare his distinctive
pageboy haircut and tanned face to the world.
Seeing how "He-Man and the Masters
of the Universe" developed from a
toy line into an animated series is interesting
because it reveals how He-Man's story
world has been regularly reimagined.
Mattel included a mini-comic with its
action figures that helped flesh out the
characters' backstories. Originally, He-Man was
a barbarian from an Eternian tribe that existed
in a post-apocalyptic world. Armed with advanced
weaponry, He-Man defended Castle Grayskull from
his enemy Skeletor. Interestingly, He-Man and
Skeletor both possessed half of the original
Power Sword, which reflected the way kids could
combine the action figure swords into one.
By 1983, Mattel had partnered with Filmation
to develop a He-Man cartoon that provided
He-Man's most popular origin. Now
he was Prince Adam of Eternia,
who had been endowed with the power to transform
into He-Man using the Power Sword. This power
was given to him by The Sorceress of Castle
Grayskull. Adam could also turn his cowardly
pet Cringer into the fearsome Battle-Cat, and
fought with his allies against Skeletor's forces.
Other cartoons continued tweaking He-Man's
origin. In "The New Adventures of He-Man,"
He-Man was summoned to the
future to defend mankind,
reviving his science fiction roots. In the 2002
"He-Man and the Masters of the Universe" reboot,
Adam was a spoiled teen who reluctantly became
He-Man to rescue his kingdom from Skeletor.
While most animated series keep the most popular
beats, there's always room for some revision.
He-Man may be Eternia's greatest champion,
but he has roots in another world:
Earth. According to the 1980s cartoon series,
Prince Adam's mother Queen Marlena was an
astronaut from Earth who crash-landed
on Eternia and ended up marrying the
planet's King Randor. One episode, "The Rainbow
Warrior," referenced Marlena's piloting skills,
but she was mostly relegated
to being a background player.
In 1985, the made-for-TV animated film "He-Man
& She-Ra: A Christmas Special" was released.
In the film, Grayskull's jester Orko accidentally
travels to Earth during Christmas time.
"Something tells me I'm in big trouble."
The Eternian magician brings back a couple
of Earth children, causing Queen Marlena
to reminisce about Christmas. Prince Adam
actually got to play Santa Claus at one point,
showing how Marlena had been
influencing Eternia's culture.
Most interestingly, however, it turns
out the Earth that Marlena is from
also exists in the DC Universe. This
can be seen in "DC Comics Presents #47"
where He-Man acknowledges Marlena told him stories
about Superman, the protector of her home-world.
Both He-Man and his alter ego Prince Adam were voiced
by John Erwin in the 1980s cartoon.
Erwin gave He-Man a majestic, authoritative voice
while giving Adam a more laid-back attitude.
"We have no time to lose."
"By the power of Grayskull!"
This helped differentiate the two
personas, even though the show's
original character designs made the two of them
look identical save for He-Man's darker tan.
Beyond He-Man, Erwin has an impressive list of
live-action and voice acting credits to his name,
including roles in "Rawhide," "Back to the Future
II," and "Babe." However, his most famous role
was "Morris the Cat," the feline spokesperson
and face of 9-Lives cat food during the 1970s.
Yep, the voice of He-Man got famous
delivering snarky lines as a fat orange
cat who rivaled Garfield in
deadpan humor with lines like,
"Who says I need improving?"
The He-Man cartoon probably missed out on a
golden opportunity to also cast Erwin as He-Man's
feline steed Battle-Cat. But he was voiced
by celebrated voice actor Alan Oppenheimer.
He-Man may look like a warrior straight out of the
sword-and-sorcery epics of Conan the Barbarian.
But the 1980s cartoon went out of its way to show
him dealing with problems non-violently. While he
was capable of lifting mountains and pushing a
moon out of orbit, He-Man rarely used his great
strength to hurt people. Plus, he usually limited
his punching targets to robots or buildings.
Many episodes showed him using diplomacy to
convince potential enemies to change their ways.
He even got Daimar the Demon
King to reconsider invading
Eternia in the episode "Daimar the Demon."
A lot of this is likely due to the producers
wanting parents to believe the cartoon would
teach their children good values, so they could
keep watching the show and buying the toys.
Much like "G.I. Joe," the episodes
even regularly ended with a moral.
Prince Adam, Teela, or the other
characters instructed viewers on
the importance of telling the truth or
working problems out by asking for help.
Superheroes typically wear a symbol or emblem
that represents their power — from Superman's
"S"-shaped family crest to Batman's bat totem. In
He-Man's case, the character designers initially
placed an Iron Cross in the center of his
chest harness to enhance his distinctive look.
The problem was, the Iron Cross was appropriated
by the Nazi party who placed a swastika symbol
in its center. Notably, the swastika itself is an
ancient symbol that had been used as a symbol of
well-being by many societies before Adolf Hitler
appropriated it for the Nazi flag. As a result,
any positive connotations of these symbols
have been overshadowed by their negative use.
And, they continue to be employed as a
hate symbol by extremist groups today.
Naturally, He-Man didn't wear
a swastika on his Iron Cross,
and being a hero of the planet Eternia, the
symbol likely meant something different.
But it was eventually realized that his chest
emblem could get people thinking the wrong thing.
Because of this, more modern depictions of He-Man
have modified the Iron Cross into an "H" symbol.
Mattel came out with a lot of creative action
figures when it developed the original He-Man
toy line. But, the weirdest characters were
members of Skeletor's entourage. Many of them,
particularly Evil-Lyn and Beast Man, went on
to become major figures in the animated series.
One action figure was so ridiculous the story
editors vowed to never use him in the cartoon.
That would be "Stinkor," a humanoid skunk whose
"power" was that he smelled really bad and gave
off toxic odors. Mattel manufactured the toy
to intentionally smell bad by treating it with
musky-smelling patchouli oil. And then it earned
a reputation for stinking up toy boxes nationwide.
Stinkor's action figure also came with a
mini-comic, "The Stench of Evil," where he
attacked He-Man with his horrible body odor, but
when the character was presented to the Filmation
staff, they reportedly burst out laughing
and decided to keep him out of their scripts.
Stinkor finally made it to television
in the 2002 "He-Man" cartoon reboot,
where it was revealed that he was once a thief
who became mutated by a chemical accident.
Notably, Stinkor isn't nose blind to
his stink and must wear an oxygen mask,
making his ability one of the
worst superpowers to have.
While He-Man was marketed toward boys, girls
liked the "Masters of the Universe" too.
Mattel decided to capitalize on this
by creating He-Man's twin sister Adora,
a.k.a "She-Ra." She was given her own toy line
and an animated series called "She-Ra: Princess
of Power." She-Ra defended the world of Etheria
from the Evil Horde after being given a "Sword of
Protection" that imbued her with superhuman
strength, speed, durability, and agility.
Although She-Ra was established
as He-Man's physical equal,
she may have been his superior in at least
one respect — her "Sword of Protection"
could transform into anything she required.
Various episodes of her cartoon showed She-Ra
turning the sword into a rope, a shield, a
boomerang, a magnet, and even an ice maker.
Frankly, by the time She-Ra started
turning her sword into a parachute,
things got a little ridiculous.
While fans may now look back on the original
"He-Man" animated series with fondness,
many admit the cartoon's plots
could get a little silly.
Filmation managed to get some serious
talent working on these episodes, however,
and many of their staff members went on to
have major careers in DC and Marvel Comics.
Bruce Timm and Paul Dini, the minds
behind the DC Animated Universe that
included the award-winning "Batman:
The Animated Series," "Batman Beyond,"
and "Justice League Unlimited," got
their start on the He-Man cartoon.
Timm worked as a background artist and layout
designer who also wrote He-Man mini comics.
Dini was a script writer for the cartoon and wrote
episodes such as "Quest for He-Man,"
where He-Man was rendered amnesic and
banished to a contaminated planet to
teach kids about the dangers of pollution.
Likewise, J. Michael Straczynski, who
had runs on "The Amazing Spider-Man"
and "Fantastic Four" for Marvel Comics,
served as the story editor for both "He-Man"
and "She-Ra." It might not be as slick
as today's animated series, but for many,
"He-Man and the Masters of the Universe" helped
pave the modern age of superhero animated shows.
He-Man may be "the most powerful man
in the universe," but how does he
stack up against the other "most
powerful hero in the universe,"
Superman? As it turns out, the comics have
addressed this question multiple times.
"DC Comics Presents" #47 saw Superman transported
to Eternia by a mystic cloud where he met up with
He-Man. Although the two started out as allies,
Skeletor was able to take magical control of
Superman and pit him against He-Man. While
it looked like Superman had the upper hand,
he was able to shake off Skeletor's
control and break off his attack.
However, Superman and He-Man had a much
more brutal fight in the "Injustice vs.
Masters of the Universe" miniseries that came out
in 2018. It took place in the Injustice Universe
where Superman became the dictator of Earth. The
story saw several DC heroes journey to Eternia and
recruit He-Man to fight the Man of Steel.
While He-Man's mystical power allowed him
to pummel Superman, some manipulation
by Skeletor caused He-Man to lose his
connection to Grayskull's magic. This caused
him to revert back to Prince Adam, leaving him
at the mercy of Superman, who considered
him less of a threat than Captain Carrot.
He-Man is often compared to Conan the Barbarian,
but there's one other superhero he shares a lot
in common with — Billy Batson, a.k.a the DC hero
known as Shazam or Captain Marvel. Like Billy,
Prince Adam is a young man imbued with mystical
powers that allow him to become a mighty hero.
Superman himself made this connection
in the "Injustice vs. Masters of the
Universe" miniseries, and fortunately
for Adam, so did a certain Wizard.
During the course of the story, Skeletor managed
to steal the Power of Shazam and attempted to use
it to conquer Eternia. Instead, he got himself
killed and inadvertently passed the power of the
gods to Prince Adam, who was summoned before the
Wizard as his new champion. By simply shouting
"Shazam!" Adam transformed into a white-garbed
being with similarities to both Shazam and
He-Man. Newly empowered, the Shazam He-Man made
short work of the corrupt Injustice Superman.
It was a scene bursting with fanboy energy,
although He-Man later went back to his
standard look and powers. While this might
disappoint some crossover fans, when you're
already the most powerful man in the universe,
being a super-strong barbarian is enough.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more LOOPER videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.